the Joe Rogan experience yeah I've ate
some weird stuff yes yes yes yeah that's
fair yeah I don't know if I buy
investigate everything I eat no never
Dave Chappelle gave me some edibles the
other day I don't know where Dave
Chappelle though if you read it I mean
it bro in a bag you probably made
himself pretty sure he ate mushrooms
from a fan the other day
that's so gangster that's so high we
went to see Once Upon a Time in America
like you talk in the morning Dave rented
out the entire movie theater we do this
[ __ ] sold-out show in the Tacoma Dome
we break the all-time attendance record
for the Tacoma Dome 25,000 people it was
madness right we're flying high it's
insane it was insane whose else's who
opens for you well it's Ashley Barnhill
she goes on she does 10 minutes and then
Ian Edwards goes on murders it and then
I go on murdered it it was a [ __ ]
crazy intermission there's a DJ's got a
hype man chuckles people are get
drinking [ __ ] flights and everything
it's madness
okay then Donna shows on murders murders
then Dave goes on lights the place on
fire piss is gasoline on the flames
then afterwards he and I go on stage
together and when he's me to get Renee
with the crowd Darnell's got a
microphone he's doing it the crowd with
20 [ __ ] 5000 people people are
rushing the stage it's madness
I mean madness what questions did you
get Bram judge [ __ ] people are just if
everyone's Drive sure Dave the show is
five hours old by the time this is
happening I'm not exaggerating we go on
stay this shows supposed to start at
8:00 probably starts at 8:30 9 10 11 12
the show was at least at least three and
a half four hours old by the time was
over so the show ends like a 12:30 ish
we go immediately from the arena
straight to a movie theater the David
rent it out we have a private screening
of Once Upon a Time in Hollywood at one
o'clock in the morning Daisy mushrooms
that some [ __ ] guy gave them in the
crowd did you eat them - OH
too smart for that
fool me once shame on you shame on me
is that us up there yeah bro is nuts it
was like the movie
long-long at 1:00 in the morning we got
out of there 4:30 in the morning then we
get on a jet in the moor at 10:00 we fly
to Salt Lake City and immediately
everybody gets a IV vitamin drip well
that day said I oh yeah yeah b12 shots
these [ __ ] go rock special rock
star style fashion he's got sunglasses
on the entire time the whole crew is
getting he has a posse with him he
brings his own photographer it was
madness legend I was like okay I see how
you guys are doing it oh we get by the
way we get picked up at the airport in a
tour bus takes a tour bus ten minutes in
a tour bus to the airport from the
airport to the hotel and you're flying
privately soon right why why drive
around an SUV we could driving a [ __ ]
tour but that's for [ __ ] it's
hilarious wow so much fun how did this
but this is what I was wondering so were
you and Dave at the store and a was like
who asks who like you're both Titans
Dave called up my well he called up his
agent I want to do a show with Joe Rogan
and then his agent calls up my agent and
they call me and I go I'm in let's do it
and then guys tacks out they're like yo
what's going down no business is all
business just met at the arena well look
I love that guy so yes know each other
you see yeah so he says you know when
they say it I'm like yeah let's do it
it sounds like an awesome idea and I'm
free that weekend great idea it was only
like five weeks out this show sells out
24 hours he doesn't have social media no
but that was the thing is that since he
doesn't have social media and I do it
like magnifies everything cuz with all
the [ __ ] people that I have 7 million
on Instagram and 5 million on Twitter
and 2 million on Facebook it's like all
of that [ __ ] and then the part of the
end I mention it on the podcast we
didn't forget everything we have you
didn't have to it seems like secret
shows that sell out in like 30 seconds
exactly
well he does a lot of clubs and theaters
and does whatever he wants he said he's
a free bird you know I'm saying like
he's free he just does whatever he wants
he wears his own clothes to it does you
know that great
I love it man I could love it he's
living wild man you guys gonna do more
together [ __ ] yeah where I scheduling
them I can't say anything cuz they're
not so schedule we had a great goddamn
time I - what drives me nuts was for any
artists out there your guys's art and I
said I text you this you - then take
this hi everyone
you two are [ __ ] legends man for you
to to get together and do shows is
insane and to use like [ __ ] that me or
Callen use to promote the show stroke
drove me nuts
it's not though joke for the fans if you
get a dope [ __ ] artist to do
something of you and Dave Chappelle it's
not for you I'm sure we will in the
future any artist please may run off
some t-shirts in Salt Lake City just a
small batch for the [ __ ] of it there's
one I sent to Jamie it's jay-z and mm in
New York like two Titans come together
man when I saw what you guys are posting
I was like God [ __ ] yeah you
worry about that too much I don't know I
don't I'm a fan that thinks that that's
a history well we'll iron that out
because we're gonna do a gang more of
these so we'll iron all that [ __ ] out
okay I'm sure Dave cares but he doesn't
have social media no he doesn't even pay
attention he's he's the the freest guy
I've ever met in terms of not being
locked into his phone he didn't even
look at his phone I didn't even have it
on him let's me toes got a phone but he
don't look at they didn't [ __ ] with and
he didn't get his phone calls you know
it's like he face times people and [ __ ]
he's not checking social media at all
did you learn anything from him just
being around him well that is
interesting
well I this is what I learned there's
levels to everything and he's on this
like super celebrity rock star level
that's really weird it's really weird
but he's so nice he's so like he's so
fun to be around like part of why Dave
is so funny is cuz he's fun like when
you're around him it's not like he's
serious and then he goes on stage and
then he's funny ya know all day long all
day long it's like leg slapping and
looking in the eyes and [ __ ] cracking
and high-fiving it's fun man he's a fun
dude but he's also he's very wise he's
his approach like for instance he lives
in the middle of Ohio in a [ __ ] farm
and that's by design because he does
away from all the ways to get away from
all the [ __ ] noise man he wants you
know he wants peace and quiet mixed in
with these intermittent bouts of madness